Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Doom.
Now, Doom is very important to me.
Not necessarily this game, but what it represents in PC gaming.
Because the original Doom is one of the first games that I EVER played.
When my dad first introduced me to computers
and gaming in general,
this was the first game that I touched
and it's the first game that I sat down and played
over and over and over again
and I played the Demo version,
and then he got me the full game,
and it was just an absolute awesome time.
And I'm gonna play it on 'Ultra-Violence'
just because I'm actually pretty decent
at first-person shooters
and I want to give myself some kind of a challenge.
There's obviously 'Nightmare' and 'Ultra-Nightmare' afterwards.
Now, when I look at games like this
I intentionally don't go into details
about what the game is about,
so this might not be-
[Game narration begins]
oo!
Rip and tear!
RIP AND TEAR!!
I love it, I LOVE IT!
That might be a reference to the Doom-
Oh, hello!
What is that?
Hi!
Ohh.
Seems like, seems like a scene from Outlast.
Oh hi, could you back away a little bit?
Ohhhh, hi.
Oh my god!
[Sadistic laughter]
Oh, man.
Oh! Am I playing right now?
I'm playing RIGHT now!
Holy shit, that's what I like,
getting right into the action!
Okay, so-
Oh hello, didn't see you there.
Okay, so I played just a test map
on the, ah, the SnapMaps
which is the customizable maps that you guys
in the community can make.
But the thing about this game is,
and what scared me in the original was that
it's very inspired by the hellish nature of hell
and all that that represents.
But in reality,
I'm not entirely sure how much-- hello -- that translates to this one.
Who are you?
Ohhh, man.
This is like a combination of technology
and like, like satanic things
and it's kinda cool, because-
(We've got to contain this...)
Oh, okay.
We have to...
contain me?
Are you talking about me? Because I was on that table by myself.
Okay. So-
Ohhhh.
Hello!
[Laughs] It's so cool!
I'm sorry, I'm nerding out.
I get so jazzed up about these-
Hello...
[Cool, slightly demonic-sounding effects]
... Well then.
That was amazing!
Nice transition for me putting on the suit!
I'm sure it didn't seem like I got naked or anything.
Aww, that's so cool.
See, I'm a little concerned
Demonic Invasion in progress
Well, we're getting right to the quick of it
ok, oh boy
Well you just said demonic attack
So it's obviously from hell
See, uh , what I don't know about this game
compared to like Doom 3
Okay?
Is that what I gotta do?
Resource operation satellite gotta be aligned?
Oh god, it's Dr. Hayden.
I'm on your side
I'm definitely not possessed by demons or my suit
But it must everything about me possessed by demons
But its kinda cool Dr. Samuel
We kinda get along just fine
I have a funny feeling that we the best of friends
Holy shit, what is that?
Aww man, sorry, didn't mean to punch you bro.
Wow.
Ho-ho-ho-holy shit.
Oh man,
I could go on for hours and hours
talking about- ooh, hello. Press F.